The Bay of Fundy in eastern Canada
has the highest tides in the world,
anything up to 16 metres difference
between low tide and high tide.
And the effects of that show up
in a few places around here.
Like Hopewell Rocks, where I'm not
standing on a beach right now,
I'm standing on the ocean floor.
That's how far the tide is out.
Actually, I'm kind of
sinking into it.
But in a few hours' time,
those rocks will be
half-way underwater,
and if I stuck around,
I would be drowning in very cold,
very fast and very deep ocean.
But I'm not going to do that!
Instead, I'm going to go about
40km that way, to--
--Moncton. It's the next morning,
it's very cold,
and I'm flying a drone to try and
get a shot of the tidal bore.
This is one of the few places in
the world where, every high tide,
a wave of water washes upstream
against the current.
But the most obvious sign of the tides
around here is in--
--Saint John, at the Reversing Falls,
where a massive river
meets the Bay of Fundy
at a narrow channel
filled with rocks and snags.
This isn't just a tidal river:
it's a tidal set of rapids.
Calling it a "waterfall"
is maybe a bit generous,
but at low tide the water
definitely has a gradient,
it drops a couple of metres in height
over a really short distance.
And then a few hours later at--
--high tide, the whole
flow reverses,
and the river's dropping a few
metres in height the other way.
And so the obvious question I had was:
why has nobody turned that bay
into a power station yet?
Actually, question number one:
why are the tides so high here?
To answer that, I'll use the
bathtub in my hotel room.
For this "scientifically-rigorous"
demonstration,
the Bay of Fundy is represented
by the bathtub,
and the Atlantic tides and all
the unimaginable pressure
created by megatonnes of water
is represented by...
...my arm. So.
Moon pulls on the ocean, tide
comes in, pressure gets applied,
and a wave heads down the bathtub,
the Bay of Fundy, and bounces back.
'Cos it's not like the water
all rises simultaneously.
It takes time, and yes, the scale
here is colossally different,
but you still get a wave effect,
a reflection, and a trough
that follows the wave.
Tick, tock. Tick, tock.
And that will always take
roughly the same time
to go up and bounce back,
it'll be affected a little bit by
the weather and water temperature.
So what happens when the
next tide comes in?
If I time each push to go with
the wave that's already there,
then very quickly, you start seeing
a resonant frequency,
and a lot of power...
Wah!
That worked way better
than I expected it to!
The resonant frequency of the
Bay of Fundy is roughly 12½ hours,
the same as the tidal cycle.
Combine that with geography
that's less like a bathtub
and more like a funnel,
getting tighter and tighter
as that wave comes in,
and you have the highest tides
in the world, right there.
The power is immense
and it's obvious.
And if it could be harnessed,
then it'd be reliable and renewable.
Intermittent, sure,
but on a schedule
that would be simple for the grid
to predict and plan around.
So why aren't there tidal power stations
all around the Bay of Fundy?
Well, the answer is: it's been tried.
A lot. Usually in the--
--Minas Basin, where several companies
have put millions and millions of dollars
behind technical trials.
And every time, the Bay of Fundy
breaks the turbines!
2009: a turbine was "torn apart".
2010: two blades "broken off".
2018: "damaged beyond repair".
Turbines in these waters have
to be light enough to spin,
but strong enough to resist
high speed salt water
that carries huge amounts of sediment
and big rocks along with it,
and in winter, enormous
chunks of sea ice.
Oh, and that's before we even
start talking about the concerns
from First Nations peoples
and commercial fishing operations
that maybe putting a load of
giant spinning things in the water
might cause some problems for fish.
But people are still trying, there are
more experimental turbines planned.
Can it be done?
Maybe.
I thought about doing long interviews
with the tidal power companies
and their opponents around here,
but those interviews would have
sounded the same twenty years ago.
And the result would have just been
a much longer way of saying:
maybe.
If it can ever be done,
safely and reliably,
it'd be brilliant,
I hope that happens.
But there's also a decent chance
that the Bay of Fundy
is just going to tear the
turbines apart again,
and in twenty years, the answer
still will be: maybe.
And now, today's--
--sponsor. I saved $200 on the
rental car that got me here,
because I used NordVPN.
Turns out some car rental companies
charge locals more:
same car, same contract,
same everything,
I went all the way to the
final checkout to make sure.
But because I’d clicked NordVPN’s
magic button that let me pretend
I was still back in the UK,
I got quoted the UK price,
which is a lot cheaper.
I’ve no idea why, but that one
transaction was worth way more
than what I paid for a
two-year subscription.
Plus, being in Canada,
some British sites
keep trying to be helpful and
automatically redirect me to .ca domains,
or even occasionally say
that I can’t access them at all
because I’m not a local.
Now I can say my phone or laptop
are in the UK,
or any one of about sixty
other countries if I want,
and a lot of stuff
just works for me.
On my laptop and my phone,
up to six devices at the
same time if I wanted.
If you go to nordvpn.com/tomscott,
you’ll find the best deal
they’re currently offering,
and there’s a 30-day
money-back guarantee,
just in case you change your mind
the same way
this waterfall changes direction.